With a runtime of 130 minutes, Thor: Ragnarok
isn't exactly a short movie, but it would
have been a lot longer if director Taika Waititi
had gotten his way.
Much of Waititi's method relied on improv,
so he encouraged leading man Chris Hemsworth
to ad-lib with his co-stars, which meant that
tons of the material they filmed didn't end
up being used in the final film.
While a good chunk of that footage probably
belonged on the cutting room floor, there
were some moments of pure gold that had to
be removed due to time restraints.
Thanks to the home video extras, here's a
look at the scenes you didn't get to see in
Thor: Ragnarok.
Playing charades
The Grandmaster, played hilariously by Jeff
Goldblum, teaches Topaz the meaning of hand
signals in one extended scene which carries
on after Loki and Valkyrie are tasked with
capturing the escaped Thor.
When they fail to understand the meaning of
his "go" signal, he starts ranting about all
the ways to tell people to do something without
ever having to open your mouth.
"This means 'go' did you get that?
That's the universal sign, was I not clear?
For heaven's sakes, what did you make of that?"
He then proceeds to teach Topaz about the
signals that he promises are universal, although
she struggles to grasp them.
"What's this?"
"Dial it down."
"THAT'S dial it down."
Meeting the Grandmaster
The Grandmaster makes a bit more of an impression
on Thor in an extended scene showing their
first meeting.
The scene begins with Thor, freshly arrived
in the Grandmaster's palace, trying to escape,
while the celestial being sends his many followers
after a frustrating flying creature.
"There it goes!
Go quickly.
Holy cats."
After everyone else departs, the Grandmaster
tells Thor about the obedience discs, the
chip implanted in his neck that keeps him
from escaping.
"It's a little invention of mine, by the way.
You know, some people find it kind of erotic."
You know this part: the Grandmaster turns
his attention to Thor, asking the hero to
introduce himself.
With a great amount of effort, Thor identifies
himself as the god of thunder before The Grandmaster
then takes Thor to see his interrogation of
his cousin Carlo.
His crimes?
"A small camel."
"He said it was only a small camel."
"What did you do to a small camel?"
After a bit more back-and-forth, the clip
ends with Carlo being pardoned… from life.
Thor gets used to his new roommate
Thor and the Hulk made a pretty great pair
in Thor: Ragnarok, but they didn't exactly
start out on good footing.
After their big fight, the pair had to get
used to rooming together, and an extended
scene of the two in their quarters shows that
figuring out how to get along wasn't easy.
The extended scene begins with Thor once again
trying to remove his obedience disc.
The noise wakes up a sleeping Hulk, who has
to shake off a "bad dream" that seems to have
involved Bruce Banner trying to regain control
of his own body.
Like the final film, Hulk ultimately wins
out and starts pestering his roommate for
seeming "sad."
Hulk antagonizes the title hero and eventually
knocks him over before Thor caves to admit
what's bothering him and starts kicking things
around the room.
But if there's one thing you don't mess with,
it's Hulk's necklace.
"Don't kick my beads!"
"I'll kick whatever I want to kick.
Stomp on your stupid beads!"
And then, Hulk lets loose with the worst insult
he can think of.
"Stupid idiot."
"You stupid white man!"
Ouch.
Skurge finds Heimdall
Skurge went through a long journey in Thor:
Ragnarok, going from an undervalued soldier
to Hela's executioner to the savior of Asgard.
Although the character was featured quite
a lot in the film, there was one scene that
didn't make the cut, showing him finding one
of Hela's most wanted — Heimdall.
In the clip, Skurge appears to be trying to
get his bearings after Hela's destruction
of the Asgardian army when he spots a group
of people fleeing in the distance.
He pulls out a pair of binoculars and trains
them on Heimdall, who turns around and looks
directly towards Skurge before fleeing.
There's no word on why the filmmakers decided
not to keep the scene, as it would've hinted
early on that Skurge would be willing to defy
Hela's orders if it meant saving his friends.
Still, the movie worked just fine without
the moment, and it made Skurge's eventual
change of heart even more surprising.
Hulk chases Thor through Sakaar
Thor's escape from the Grandmaster's headquarters
was nothing short of heroic in the film, and
a deleted scene gives even more of a glimpse
at just what he had to go through to get out.
In the clip, Thor jumps out the window of
the Grandmaster's palace, but he's followed
by an angry Hulk, who wants him to stay.
Hulk crashes through the marketplace, greeted
with cheers from the locals everywhere he
goes.
He follows a somersaulting, running Thor throughout
the colorful city until Thor finally makes
it to the junkyard where finds the former
Avengers ship.
There isn't much to the scene, but it shows
more of Sakaar, and how its people react to
their champion, which starkly contrasts with
how he's regarded back on Earth.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!